there's a lot about your career that's
well did you enjoy that's been good to
you you don't love this nickname that's
been following you around the golden
tour so I mean how do you that's
literally that I mean how do you live
like a German restaurant how do you live
up to the golden tour so you don't you
don't
yeah I thought it was an editor of GQ
Jim Orr who did it yeah you know when I
was modeling years yeah look it's not
something that hasn't stuck with my
mates right it's not like your friends
aren't saying you know no yeah that's
good
yeah it's like you know with my mates
it's all like just surnames and sort of
stupid name - ha
no one's going like you're ruined Gordon
- like no not like it's just not right
it doesn't like you know there could be
worse you know I've been called bloated
fish you know yeah be rotting chicken
breast I can call your pale though yeah
I'm gonna be golden as one saying no no
I love it when a guy from where I where
are you from again northern Northern
Ireland is giving me [ __ ] about being
pale what I love is that you are getting
away with it because I've lived in this
my people have in this country for like
150 years and I'm still usually the
whitest person when I walk into a room I
have no I can't mean you can get a tan
at least I can get out or I'm forced to
like you know what I was modeling these
two I guess sometimes there's a campaign
you're doing or whatever and the whole
thing is like sort of pasty pale like
people look like they're kind of dying
or
but to like or project is not like
suffering oxygen tank no like it may see
it at pale people like you selling
clothes yeah and then there's sometimes
I want you to be sort of that bronzed up
and whatever so I've had some you know
awkward see just standing there in sort
of Christ pose while people that you
don't really know we're sort of rubbing
oil and I'm timing my god that's a dream
I've had often just means standing there
being rubbed well you've got a little
bit of that you've got the dark Irish
I've got that ginger thing where if I go
in the Sun I just get sort of pink red
immediately and I look like an alcoholic
you and you can get that sort of you
know that you can get that swarthy look
I think probably yeah but it's not
usually because someone's pasted
something on my face
right right I'm wearing this is six
hours of makeup this right here this is
me dipping my head into a toilet bowl
full of makeup why did I make it a
toilet pool mistake it could be a
regular Bowl but you don't like it that
I made it a toilet bowl yeah humble
you